with a quick wit and a little panache
Michael Ian Black has established
himself as one of the most distinctive
voices in the comedy game can you give
me the remover from his from Mike hunt
please I just want to get the room can I
get to remember from Mike hunt they're
pranking me back i pranked em they
fighting me what a great hotel strap in
and get ready for a non-stop pro ride of
man's blow civ proportions
this is chiku's how to be a man today
Michael Ian Black shows us how to be
classy well you're not famous
first thing you gotta do get nice hotel
put it on the card and just take that
attitude of money's no object you know
can I get a quick up bottle of water
thing if these things you're actually
six bucks so I don't I can give you
money if you want yeah give me like ten
four need to have an assistant you know
somebody who can act as kind of a buffer
between me and the world cuz the moat
the main thing is you want to have a
bubble okay so hey that's not got Tammy
here for Oh God that must be I Timmy
is it okay I mean wait until I say it's
time to talk before you talk okay now
you can talk it's great and I don't miss
my fee I don't miss my family at all go
in the bathroom so you don't get two
rooms when when you travel with your
assistant or no she says she stays in
the tub
you know my kids who I love more than
life itself that's so great and so when
I have to leave them you know yeah
that's for hey do you want to stop
filming or no this I want you to film it
I think I want you to see I want I want
you to film that I'm like should I cry
too
nah uh-uh no don't cuz I want it to be
about making be independent stand on
your own two feet you just I just had my
don't feign knowledge this hotel was
actually built by Barack Obama in that's
me treat others the way you want to be
true if I can pay her less I would but I
can't because I'm not paying her
anything
thanks for teaching us how to be classy
my pleasure I have to see one thing I'm
pregnant with Michaels baby
Tammi is pregnant you don't have you
don't know no no Jason guys that we
don't need this to be in class he is
telling the truth Tammy do me a favor
pack up your [ __ ] and go get the car and
I will be down in about five minutes
okay like what are you gonna do you're
gonna leave your wife and kids no I'm
not gonna leave my wife and kids she's
gonna get the car I'm gonna going at the
back to learn disappear unknown okay
hopefully she forgets about it
yeah Michael Ian Black ciao what up man
before I'll see videos that teach you
how to be a man subscribe to our YouTube
channel and follow us on Twitter